When we bought this house in 1988, it came with two outdoor feral cats.
And then one of them was killed, hit by a car.
And then the second one was hit by a car...
...and had to go to the vet for quite a bit of reconstructive surgery.
So, we made her an indoor cat and then to get her company,...
...'cause the other one had been killed,...
...we went to the shelter and adopted a couple of cats...
...and that's just started down the road.
The cat walks, I think the first one I built in 1995, actually was this one.
For the walks, just the walks, I've probably spent 40 or $50,000.
And they can be done a lot cheaper, but the cat walks are for the cats.
They're also for me.
They're architecturally interesting to me, the colors...
...and we always try to do something interesting with the shapes.
There's spirals, there's bridges, there's arc bridges.
A lot of the tunnels have faces on them.
And one of my favorites is in the upstairs bathroom, there's a tunnel with a shark.
And the carpenters actually made teeth and when the cats walk through the teeth,...
...they scratch the back of the cat.
So, the cats like to go back and forth through that.
So, you can't really feel ever there's 15 cats...
...because they never assemble in one group.
And they're very calming.
So, I like them 'cause when you come home and if you're stressed...
...and if you sit down, two or three will come and purr and it just relaxes you.